[Music]
hello conan o'brien here with an update
on our vote for our first guest poll
now as you remember we started with 12
candidates now that we're getting closer
to november 8th i think it's time we get
serious i'm going to cut some dead
weight all right first up justin bieber
justin bieber is very popular a lot of
votes i just learned several hours ago
justin bieber has a concert the same
night as our first show
you're probably thinking why didn't i
look into that i didn't because i'm just
shocked that his parents would let him
perform on a school night that seems
crazy to me and irresponsible but
bieber's choice not mine he's out i'm
also eliminating pope benedict
he's opening for justin bieber that
night he's got a great act show up early
don't just go for bieber next up reo
speedwagon
it was my dream to reunite oreo
speedwagon on our first show i find out
several days ago they never broke up in
the first place i will not be made a
fool of i'm also eliminating vladimir
putin and tom from myspace
they just didn't get the votes okay they
didn't pull in the numbers they're gone
now this is a bit of a shocker but i'm
cutting loose lady gaga
i know she's very popular but apparently
the outfit lady gaga was going to wear
on our program is being protested by the
aspca the fda the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms and nasa
i'm also cutting a reclusive author
thomas pynchon
it turns out reclusive does not mean
what i thought it meant
finally i'm eliminating 2007 nobel prize
for chemistry winner gerhardt airtel
the guy's a
his ego is out of control
all right i can't accommodate his
entourage and he wanted to bring and for
me to pay for his own pastry chef forget
it stick to chemistry i'm also going to
have to let go the entire cast of the
live-action fat albert movie
these guys just don't get along dumb
donald and mushmouth don't even speak
they haven't been in the same room for
years
so where does that leave us
uh voting is now closed
it's time for me to tally and manipulate
the results
we are now looking at a choice between
jack nicholson
the sultan of brunei
and arlene wagner curator of the
leavenworth nutcracker museum
see where this thing's going anywho
who's gonna win it's all very exciting
find out on november 8th if you have
positive comments about these results go
to teamcoco.com for any negative
comments please go to
regisandkelly.go.com
and really let them have it
[Music]
hello
nicholson's out
does he know i'm on tbs
well
call the celtna brunei
we'll find his number